wenowhavearightaroundthirteenthousandofourviewersandlistenerssubscribetothedavidpakmanshowsubredditatdavidpakman.com/r
e. D. D I. T. A couple of posts I spotted
there this morning. There's a post from a
user saying David's not obligated to cover
the social justice warriors. I've seen him
talking about this and how the right says
if he does and he's a hypocrite or how he
needs to criticize the left, no, he doesn't
and he said himself, the biggest way we lose
is to divide.
They want you to talk about it nonstop because
it's the only thing they went on. My view
is a little different. Yes. I think that pointless
division of the left to our own detriment
is counterproductive and I'm trying to avoid
that. The real reason I don't get too much
into the SJW stuff is that it's quite frankly
not the most important thing going on on the
left right now. The most important thing happening
on the left is a resurgence or a renaissance
or maybe even for the first time, the taking
seriously of the actual positive progressive
movement within the Democratic Party, Bernie
and Elizabeth Warren's role as the sort of
left coalition in night. One of the second
debate on CNN earlier this week is evidence
of that all criticize a suppression of speech
attempted by the left. I'll criticize movements
on the left that I think are counterproductive,
but I'm going to criticize and cover them
in proportion to how important I think they
are.
And quite frankly, there are lots of really
great things going on, uh, in the progressive
movement that are way more important and way
more interesting. And that's why I don't go
crazy focusing on the stuff that admittedly
makes a lot of money for some online media,
just not interested in it. Another post Marianne
Williamson is really problematic. Progressive
media needs to call her out on it. The David
Pakman show, majority report Kyle Kalinsky
and TYT need to call out Marianne Williamson
instead of praising her. Following the debates
tonight, this was from a couple of days ago,
Marianne Williamson has gotten a spike of
attention from progressives and liberals alike.
Here's why it's dangerous linking to a bunch
of her wacky pseudoscience comments. Listen,
I know people get mad at me every time I say
she has all these wacky ideas she does. I
said she did well enough in this second debate
on the first night behind Bernie and Warren,
but basically doing better in terms of engaging
the audience that everybody else on that stage
did, but she has wacky ideas.
The pseudoscience stuff is wacky and I know
people have been writing to me saying, David,
you need to understand the power of belief
and she's not as crazy as you're making her
out to be. She's wacky. Okay. It's, it's okay.
It's, it's, she's not a bad person as a result
of it. Lots of people have beliefs that are
similar to hers and I've been pointing out
that she's been engaging the audience well.
She has a quirky personality and she has a
lot of really problematic beliefs in her background
period and I think that's all we have to do.
She's going to be gone soon, likely before
the next debate. Lastly, why do you think
the hatred iots frequently misspelled Pacman
as Parkman? I actually think that a lot of
it is not a Jew. It's not a people who don't
know my name. It's auto correct.
My instinct is like my phone knows pacman
because it's learned it because I type it
on my phone. Um, but my guesses that there's
probably a lot of auto correct that would
turn pacman into Parkman. And I think that
it's just a funny little feature of Patriot
male, but mostly related, I think the technology,
not, uh, anything else. Make sure you subscribe
to the David Pakman show subreddit@davidpakman.com
slash reddit